>>> GOOD MORNING.
>> LET'S GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ABOUT TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE DEBT CEILING.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> WHAT WE NEED TODAY TO RAISE
THE DEBT LIMIT AND WHY THE
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS -- WHAT
THEY'RE DOING TODAY IS SO
RECKLESS AND DANGEROUS IN MY
VIEW.
RAISING THE DEBT LIMIT COMES
DOWN TO PAYING WHAT WE ALREADY
OWE.
WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN ACQUIRED.
NOT ANYTHING NEW.
IT STARTS WITH A SIMPLE TRUTH --
THE UNITED STATES IS A NATION
THAT PAYS ITS BILLS AND ALWAYS
HAS FROM ITS INCEPTION.
WE HAVE NEVER DEFAULTED.
WHAT WE PAY FOR IS FOR IT TO
KEEP US A GREAT NATION.
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS FOR
SENIORS.
SALARIES FOR BRAVE SERVICE
MEMBERS AND BENEFITS FOR
VETERANS AND OTHER FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS FOR OUR PEOPLE AND
FOR OUR NATION.
WE'RE ABLE TO MEET THESE
OBLIGATIONS BASED ON THE REVENUE
WE RECEIVE FROM TAXES AND BASED
ON OUR ABILITY TO BORROW WHEN
NEEDED.
AND IN THAT CASE, WE'RE ABLE TO
BORROW BECAUSE WE ALWAYS PAY OUR
DEBT.
WE ALWAYS PAY WHAT WE OWE.
WE'VE NEVER FAILED.
THAT'S AMERICA.
THAT'S WHO WE ARE.
THAT'S WHAT'S CALLED FOR.
IT'S CALLED FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S ROCK SOLID, IT'S THE BEST
IN THE WORLD.
BUT HERE'S THE DEAL -- THERE'S A
CAP ON WHAT WE CAN BORROW CALLED
THE DEBT LIMIT.
AND ONLY CONGRESS CAN RAISE OR
LOWER THAT DEBT LIMIT, SO LET ME
BE REALLY CLEAR.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW.
RAISING THE DEBT LIMIT IS ABOUT
PAYING OFF OUR OLD DEBTS.
THERE'S NOTHING TO DO WITH ANY
NEW SPENDING BEING CONSIDERED.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH MY
PLAN FOR INFRASTRUCTURE OR
BUILDING BACK BETTER, ZERO,
ZERO.
BOTH OF WHICH I MIGHT ADD ARE
PAID FOR.
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE GOOD
ON WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN APPROVED
BY PREVIOUS CONGRESSES AND
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS AND PARTIES,
WE HAVE TO PAY FOR IT.
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE PROMISED
SALARIES FOR SERVICE MEN AND
WOMEN, BENEFITS FOR VETERANS.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO RAISE THE
DEBT LIMIT IF WE'RE GOING TO
MEET THOSE OBLIGATIONS.
AND RAISING THE DEBT LIMIT IS
USUALLY A BIPARTISAN
UNDERTAKING.
AND IT SHOULD BE.
THAT'S WHAT IS NOT HAPPENING
TODAY.
THE REASON WE HAVE TO RAISE THE
DEBT LIMIT IS IN PART BECAUSE OF
THE RECKLESS TAX AND SPENDING
POLICIES UNDER THE PREVIOUS
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
IN FOUR YEARS, THEY INCURRED
NEARLY $8 TRILLION, IN FOUR
YEARS, $8 TRILLION IN ADDITIONAL
DEBT AND BILLS WE HAVE TO NOW
PAY OFF.
THAT'S MORE THAN A QUARTER OF
THE ENTIRE DEBT INCURRED NOW
OUTSTANDING AFTER MORE THAN 200
YEARS.
AND REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
RAISED THE DEBT THREE TIMES WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT, AND
EACH TIME WITH DEMOCRATS'
SUPPORT.
BUT NOW THEY WON'T RAISE IT EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MORE THAN $8 TRILLION IN BILLS
INCURRED IN FOUR YEARS UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S WHAT WE'D BE PAYING OFF.
THEY WON'T RAISE IT EVEN THOUGH
DEFAULTING ON THE DEBT WOULD
LEAD TO SELF-INFLICTED WOUND
THAT TAKES OUR ECONOMY OVER A
CLIFF AND RISKS JOBS AND
RETIREMENT SAVINGS, SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS, SALARIES FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS, BENEFITS FOR
VETERANS, AND SO MUCH MORE.
A FAILURE TO RAISE THE DEBT
LIMIT WILL CALL INTO QUESTION
CONGRESS' WILLINGNESS TO MEET
OUR OBLIGATIONS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY INCURRED, NOT NEW ONES,
WE'VE ALREADY INCURRED.
THIS IS GOING TO UNDERMINE THE
SAFETY OF U.S. TREASURY
SECURITIES AND WILL THREATEN THE
RESERVE STATUS OF THE DOLLAR AS
THE WORLD'S CURRENCY, THAT THE
WORLD RELIES ON.
THE AMERICAN CREDIT RATING WILL
BE DOWNGRADED, INTEREST RATES
WILL RISE FOR MORTGAGES, AUTO
LOANS, CREDIT CARDS, AND
BORROWING.
FOLKS WATCHING AT HOME, YOU
SHOULD KNOW
THEY WON'T VOTE TO RAISE THE
DEBT LIMIT TO COVER THEIR OWN
SPENDING.
DEMOCRATS VOTED WITH THEM TO
COVER THAT SPENDING THE LAST
FOUR YEARS, PREVIOUS FOUR YEARS.
THEY SAY DEMOCRATS SHOULD DO IT
ALONE.
BUT THEN THEY'RE THREATENING TO
USE A PROCEDURAL POWER CALLED
THE FILIBUSTER, MEANING THAT
WE'D HAVE TO GET 60 VOTES, NOT
50 VOTES, TO INCREASE THE DEBT
LIMIT.
THIS WOULD BLOCK THE DEMOCRATS
FROM MEETING THEIR OBLIGATIONS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES TO PREVENT
CONGRESS FROM RAISING THE DEBT
LIMIT.
SO LET'S BE CLEAR.
NOT ONLY ARE REPUBLICANS
REFUSING TO DO THEIR JOB.
THEY'RE THREATENING TO ABUSE THE
POWER, THEIR POWER, TO PREVENT
US FROM DOING OUR JOB, SAVING
THE ECONOMY FROM A CATASTROPHIC
EVENT.
I THINK, QUITE FRANKLY, IT IS
HYPOCRITICAL, DANGEROUS, AND
DISGRACEFUL.
THEIR OBSTRUCTION AND
IRRESPONSIBILITY KNOWS
ABSOLUTELY NO BOUNDS, EXCUSE ME,
ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE CLAWING OUR
WAY OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC.
DEMOCRATS WILL MEET OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND OBLIGATION TO
THIS COUNTRY.
WE'RE NOT EXPECTING REPUBLICANS
TO DO THEIR PART.
THEY MADE THAT CLEAR FROM THE
BEGINNING.
WE TRIED ASKING TO NO AVAIL.
WE'RE JUST ASKING THEM NOT TO
USE PROCEDURAL TRICKS TO BLOCK
US FROM DOING THE JOB THAT THEY
WON'T DO.
METEOR IS HEADED TO CRASH INTO
OUR ECONOMY.
DEMOCRATS ARE WILLING TO DO ALL
THE WORK STOPPING IT.
REPUBLICANS JUST HAVE TO LET US
DO OUR JOB.
JUST GET OUT OF THE WAY.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO HELP SAVE
THE COUNTRY, GET OUT OF THE WAY
SO YOU DON'T DESTROY IT.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO DELAY WITH
ELABORATE PROCEDURAL SCHEMES,
WHICH REPUBLICANS' PROPOSALS
REQUIRE.
SCORES OF VOTES WITHOUT ANY
CERTAINTY AT ALL, MANY OF WHICH
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE DEBT
LIMIT AT ALL.
THAT'S WHEN ACCIDENTS HAPPEN.
IN THE DAYS AHEAD, EVEN BEFORE
THE DEFAULT DATE, PEOPLE MAY SEE
THE VALUE OF THEIR RETIREMENT
ACCOUNTS SHRINK.
THEY MAY SEE INTEREST RATES GO
UP, WHICH WILL ONLY RAISE THEIR
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS AND CAR
PAYMENTS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, LOOK, LET'S
JUST SAY IT THIS WAY, AS SOON AS
THIS WEEK, YOUR SAVINGS AND YOUR
POCKETBOOK COULD BE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THIS REPUBLICAN
STUNT.
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY WILL NOT DO
THEIR PART TO AVOID THIS
NEEDLESS CALAMITY.
SO BE IT.
BUT THEY NEED TO STOP PLAYING
RUSSIAN ROULETTE WITH THE U.S.
ECONOMY.
IT'S ONE THING TO PAY OUR DEBTS
ALREADY ACQUIRED.
IT'S ANOTHER TO REQUIRE A SUPER
MAJORITY TO PAY THE DEBTS
ALREADY ACQUIRED.
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
LET THE DEMOCRATS VOTE TO RAISE
THE DEBT CEILING THIS WEEK.
WITHOUT OBSTRUCTION OR FURTHER
DELAYS.
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE HAVE
ALREADY PASSED A BILL THAT WOULD
DO THAT.
IT'S SITTING IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE, WHERE DEMOCRATS
HAVE THE VOTES READY TO PASS IT.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY TO ELIMINATE
THE UNCERTAINTY AND RISK THAT'S
GOING TO HARM AMERICAN FAMILIES
AND OUR ECONOMY.
LET US VOTE AND END THE MESS.
WE'VE GOT TO GET THIS DONE.
WE MUST GET THIS DONE.
AS I SAID, IT'S PLAYING RUSSIAN
ROULETTE, TO PLAY THESE GAMES.
WE CAN DO IT THIS WEEK.
JUST GET OUT OF THE WAY, AND LET
US PASS IT.
THANK YOU.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, SENATOR MITCH
McCONNELL SAYS HE HAS SENT A
LETTER TO YOU EXPLAINING HIS
VIEW.
HAVE YOU SEEN THAT LETTER?
HAVE YOU COMMUNICATED WITH HIM?
AND HOW DIRE DO YOU BELIEVE THIS
IS IF ACTION DOESN'T TAKE PLACE
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DID GET A
LETTER.
I GOT IT TEN MINUTES BEFORE I
WALKED IN HERE.
I'VE READ IT.
I PLAN ON TALKING TO MITCH ABOUT
IT.
I HAVE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD ONCE
BEFORE BACK WHEN I WAS VICE
PRESIDENT.
I HOPE WE CAN HAVE SOME
INTELLIGENT AND HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT HE IS
PROPOSING.
I THINK THE EASIEST WAY TO DO
THIS, AND IF THE REPUBLICANS
WOULD NOT USE THE FILIBUSTER,
WOULD BE TO LET US VOTE ON WHAT
IS ALREADY IN THE SENATE RIGHT
NOW, PASSED BY THE HOUSE, TO
RAISE THE DEBT LIMIT.
WE COULD DO THAT IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL DAYS.
>> MR. PRESIDENT?
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
YOU'VE OFTEN TOUTED YOUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE SENATE, 36
YEARS IN THE SENATE.
YOUR AIDES HAVE TALKED ABOUT
YOUR ABILITIES TO BE A CLOSER ON
DEALS INVOLVING LEGISLATION.
WHY WERE YOU UNABLE, MR.
PRESIDENT, TO CLOSE THE DEAL
WITH MEMBERS OF YOUR OWN PARTY
ON KEY PARTS OF YOUR LEGISLATIVE
AGENDA LAST WEEK?
>> I WAS ABLE TO CLOSE THE DEAL
WITH 99% OF MY PARTY.
TWO, TWO PEOPLE ARE STILL ON
THEIR WAY.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN A
PRESIDENT WHO HAS BEEN ABLE TO
CLOSE DEALS IN A POSITION WHERE
HE HAS ONLY 50 VOTES IN THE
SENATE.
A BARE MAJOR